that's cardi b's name
how did i not know this
all right y'all we are right smack dab
in the middle of award season all the
hard working people the music movies and
television industry are in the spotlight
for their amazing work over the past
year if i could give y'all awards for
being the best fans i would
just
subscribe to my channel
i'm not above bribery says every parent
but did you know that many celebrities
actually don't go by their real names in
public eye so i'm going to play a game
of try and guess the celebrity from
their real names i am genuinely excited
to see how bad i am at this
let's
play
robin fenty
why does vindy sound familiar
is that rihanna she's like a product
line that's
casually billionaire is this rihanna
okay yeah oh i i you know how i knew
that
angie well i knew that because of her
product line isn't it fenty or something
yes um i did not actually know that her
name was robin
or fenty but now we do i got that one
right though that's a win
abel
tesfay
abel tesfay
i'm gonna need to phone a friend for a
hint on that one
he's not a weak that's oh abel i did
know his name was able the weekend
somebody told me that once because i
have a i have a band member named aben
and i was like oh i never heard of abel
even i mean i obviously knew
the weekend wasn't actually named the
weeknd but abel is a cool name strong
name biblical name
i'm gonna have my tea
natalie
hirschlag hershlog
natalie
herschlag
you know the more i say it i still don't
know
oscar winner
who played a first lady
that's her name
natalie portman seems like such a real
name that was her name
i know this john stevens this is this is
john legend i know this one yes
and then i found that i was like you
named yourself legend
that's awesome
my name is kelly icon
it's gonna stick
[Applause]
peter hernandez
i don't know
your third favorite super bowl halftime
performer my third
oh that's bruno mars that's his name
oh my gosh i wonder where he came up
with bruno mars there's prob that's out
there somewhere someone's asked him that
before i'm gonna google that
norma jean baker
norma jean baker i don't know but i feel
like she's from texas
i believed men prefer blonde is that uh
marilyn monroe's name
whoa
her name was norm everything wow okay
i would have never guessed her name was
norma jean how country does that sound i
never picture very country that's
awesome
aubry graham
aubry graham
is it anything like this name or no
no
canadian rapper who likes to be called
on his self you used ogami i know
drake okay
i like drake here's the best part of
drake that i'm gonna out myself for
right now so i'm ha with my band and
we're
talking about songs like because we
cover a lot of songs on the show
whatever and i'm like and they were like
why are you covered drink it and i'm
like i don't know i really like i think
i have covered like one of his just hold
on
so somehow
in drake's entire career the songs that
i've heard from drake he's like singing
more in them and all of a sudden i was
listening to the song
i was like damn i was like whose song is
this and lester was like that's drake
and i was like what i thought he was
like like a singer and had like really
cool beats like i've heard him before i
did not know it was the same person
anyway didn't know it was aubrey graham
either
stefani steph stephanie or stefani i
don't know stephanie
german nada
i don't know that one
you may or may not be able
that's lady gaga's name
her name is stephanie
i didn't know that german nada that's
cool very italian it is very italian
i love that i said stuff fanny
look i was on a show with gwen so when i
see that it looks like stefani
i knew that her name wasn't lady gaga
but i didn't know that her name was
stephanie i don't feel like i've ever
heard that before
eric bishop
i don't know this one eric bishop so
it's probably eric still right academy
award winner who plays
villain electro and spider-man
electro which one is electro that's not
jamie foxx is an electro is it
it is jamie oh my god i was like wait he
is the one with the energy oh my god his
name is eric
and foxy once again he and legend they
were like we're just putting it out
there i'm a fox and i'm a legend i love
it i love the confidence fellas
oh i know this one alicia moore this is
pink
because i'm obsessed with her i love her
she's amazing i got to perform with her
at the american music awards i believe
it was i was so
i don't get nervous and i was so nervous
because you know we're in each other's
like in-ears that's like real close and
i was like don't suck
because
she's right there like i was very
nervous and i sometimes when girls sing
together they always like try and like
outrun each other and i thought both of
us
really played it cool which i which is
so pink she's so cool but like you know
we really just kind of stayed in you
know and i feel like some girls always
do that thing where there's like
everybody's like arguing over their
rifts and so i liked that that was a fun
performance it was a cool song too she's
red
catherine hudson i mean i'm gonna say
that's kate hudson right
okay it's not kate hudson okay she's a
california girl that doesn't limit it
down girl
what
oh my god what's happening
is that a song
[Laughter]
wait what
the undeniable no nothing how does it go
[Music]
i wanna go on the record with i know a
ton of katy perry songs i don't know how
i missed this one i feel like this is
what happened on that's my jam jimmy
fallon brought out a song of ariana's i
know like so many ariana songs and he
brought out one that i maybe had heard
once
and i was so mad about it because i was
like wait it looks like i don't know
your music and i do and i know katie's
music too i yeah i totally know it i'm
just having a brain fart i didn't know
her name was katherine
have fun
belle callis
[Music]
with catchphrases like
ochre
[Music]
that's cardi b
that's cardi b's name
how did i not know this
damn
okay i did not know that that's a
that's a boss name and she's a ball so i
like it alright so let me know in the
comments if you if you knew like any of
those names or if one surprised you and
you were like what um like me
i'm still surprised and i'm still not
gonna be able to pronounce cardi b's i
feel honestly more disappointed about
not knowing the katy perry song than
anything
subscribe to my channel for more fun
with me or don't just whatever it's
dealer's choice
but you know you want to
bye
[Music]
you